[Music]
I'm Christopher Hyneman we're talking
about Bokan as we teach it here in
present so at this school the book can
work we do is based heavily on cyclist
sensei's book in work but it's also
filtered through my ideas of I've done
historical European martial arts a lot
of other different kinds of martial arts
so the other ideas that I haven't kind
of come into our weapon work one of the
key principles in understanding sword
work is understanding how to make it
successful so it might seem as simple as
an attack is just swinging and hitting
someone and a lot of schools if I could
have spent a lot of time doing savuti
for just this reason because the idea is
like if I have a perfect cut then I'll
make a good attack the problem is that
you have to always account for the other
person when you're making attacks so if
someone attacks you and or if you attack
someone and you do not account for the
fact that they can immediately attack
you back then you've made a poor attack
so all of our attacks have to have this
basic understanding so before we get to
the basic attacks that we use here in
this school we have to explain it theory
so if I get Josh in here so Josh and I
are in here sort of the sword so we have
good MA so when we're setting the ma
here an important thing to understand is
that if I don't take a step I can't
reach Josh and that's Epps really
important to judge just like in regular
on your theory that step gives you
enough of reaction time to deal with
whatever I'm bringing so good my eye is
just the tips of our sword touching and
if I don't take a step I can't quite hit
this guy so we're a good mom here if
jobs for two to come in and make an
attack on an angle like this and I'm
immediately able to get Josh back that
attack was a poor attack and the reason
is because my arms will move so fast at
this range that it's very unlikely that
he'll be able to get his sword down and
defend before I can attack him so he's
exposed himself here in this so what
Josh wants to do when he lands
if you want to attack in a way at that
angle then an eye were immediately
counter I cannot get to him right so
right now I'm swimming right through and
the reason is because at this high
position Joshua the better line than I
have I mean he can make full contact
with me here while I can't make contact
with him and the reason is simply
because as my lever goes lower and lower
lower
it becomes shorter because of the arc of
my arm set me in see how far I am from
his ankle I'm very far from his ankle I
couldn't make an ankle attack it can't
make a knee attack
I can't make a body attack now we're a
good search I make an attack is on the
same line josh is on however Josh's
sword is right there protect me so if I
were to try to hit Josh's head back then
it would be he would be defended against
that now it's important to understand I
did get hit right so if Josh was only
attack desire was to hit me and kill me
or hurt me or whatever then that's fine
he's made a successful attack however if
Jocelyn's preserve himself at all he
would have made it in successful and
unsuccessful attack and when he hit I
was still able to get him so Josh needs
to learn this distance so one thing we
can do I'll hold the sword out for Josh
we can see every time yep I could hit
him but he cannot count the counter hit
me back so that's one part of this being
able to make a successful attack another
part is you always want your sword to be
in position to create some kind of
opposing force to their sword so if
that's same thing we're gonna happen
here so we're at nice five and Josh
comes in and makes the attack at a good
distance now I cannot attack this body
however I could move my body or take a
step in so now understand that step so
me being able to take a step in to get
Josh get some some reaction time where
josh is placed to the sword means that
when I do that he can cut through and
protect himself with his sword
so after
yes his secondary action is his arms
moving down now its arms move faster
than either my body or my feet so that
means if I made a body adjustments he
would be able to pull his arm down in
time to account for that also my man
foot action you'd be able to bring his
arms down in time to account to death
this is the basic idea of being able to
oppose my sword called opposition so we
can oppose my sword by doing this if
jobs were to land an attack so it
started to come back here drums if
joseline make the attack on this side of
my body but when he did he were to step
forward with his right foot he would not
have this natural line so it has cuts a
little awkward for him but more
importantly it's his sword woman
absolutely moved down to protect his
body here so when I attack John because
the seeder cross and the harder and
harder time to pulling the sword down
the defendants up because he can barely
make it but it is not a good good
position for division however we make
seven time he steps forward with his
other foot now as we go to attack his
body he easily bring his hands down
naked to protect himself so this gives
him a nice alignment to create that so
when he steps in and he goes to this
side buddy Sarah different if he goes to
this side of the body he wants to have
the other foot boards this way sort of
naturally moves down to protect himself
he always wants the open side of his
body towards my next attacking positions
my next second positions here so that
means he wants to open side this body
areas up bring the sword by your side
for a second so you can see here's to be
open side of his body here's where he's
built to operate if John's weren't
stepping with the other foot when he
makes that attack you go ahead and say
and see him so now the close side of
this body is where my is going to be in
next now it's not a possible brendham to
protect himself it's just not very
efficient so
might be able to get that but it's not
gonna be nearly as easy for his feet
were switched and now you naturally take
down defend himself so understanding
this when were minivan successful attack
we always have to account for the next
shift of the person who were dealing
with right so you want to do that
ideally by perfect distancing so that
would be the great thing to do is make
an attack on a line that they do not
immediately counter-attack however you
can't do that you always want to create
a position where your sword can
immediately cover you after this option
is done so this is how to make a proper
attack in Aikido after this we're going
to talk about the five basic ways we
make proper attacks here in this school
I'm Christopher Hein thanks a lot